hi everybody welcome to our chat about
the hubble space telescope named after
Edwin Hubble and I have with me today a
Leo ball Jay iMacs lead senior engineer
and James neihaus ase director of
photography and imax traning manager and
we're here to celebrate the 10th
anniversary of the imax movie a Hubble
3d it's really a unique look into Hubble
Space Telescope's legacy and imax had a
great deal to do with making the world
really aware of of the Hubble's
telescope and looking into the stars and
understanding the universe
boolie was produced and directed by Tony
Myers and Graham Ferguson you'll see a
little bit of Tony in a video a little
bit later so I wanted to turn it over to
to my friend James neihaus who's been
working with I'm an expert for decades
trained a lot of astronauts and Trent
praying the astronauts in the NBL
tell us about the NBL James well the the
NBL is the neutral buoyancy lab it's a
big swimming pool built out by Ellington
Air Force Base in Houston that has a lot
of water in it and they're capable to
it's able to hold full-size models of
the Hubble Space Telescope so the
astronauts would go in they would suit
up and their their aviator extra
vehicular activity suits and get in the
water and do a pretend spacewalk and do
the work they were going to do in space
and practice it in the semis zero-g
environment in the swimming pool so sort
of the sitter right you see the the
Hubble underneath the two yellow
balloons that's the the Space Telescope
the the rectangular structure are
simulating the solar panels so now I
think be a good time to look at this
video that we have that you shot in the
NBL and it shows the IMX to
camera and it shows you doing all the
things you do underwater with the
astronauts that let's roll that tape
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is the IMAX 3d crew working at the
NBL which the neutral buoyancy lab at
Johnson Space Center it's where the
astronauts practice their spacewalks in
a swimming pool
they dress up in their spacesuits and up
in the water and it makes them think
they're in space
this pool is absolutely fantastic it has
6.5 million
inside the shuttle with its cargo bay
and then got the
they've got the Hubble inside a mock-up
of the Hubble studying up there and
that's how the
their space box we have two cameras we
have one on the top side that we shoot
they're suiting up
the underwater camera it goes underneath
and they're shooting all of the
there's one eye that's the left eye
here's the right eye
mirrors do take something else it up and
down
Zann makes a turn
well this is the IMAX camera you can see
the two lenses the left and right eye
lens used to make the stereo image we
shoot with it on a dolly most of the
time because the camera weighs 270 some
odd pounds here the assistants are
reloading the camera an operation that
takes about 20 minutes and about 11 feet
of film here you can see the two films
Yates the left the right eye the
magazines there are four chambers on the
back to take up to feed holds a thousand
feet of film actually two thousand feet
left and right eye goes through the
camera at about eleven feet per second
so that's quite a commitment when you
turn the camera on to run you want to
make sure everything is absolutely right
at that one
this is a film about it's the life story
of the hubble space telescope
and it's the first time we'll be seeing
it in 3d we have filmed it before
back in 89
since we shot the original Hubble deploy
and first repair mission in IMAX the
company has come up with a system to
convert 2d to 3d so fortunately we will
be able to
see all this great footage was shot back
in nineteen eighty nine nineteen
three in 3d in the finished film you
know you're underwater during your scuba
tank and you know you can move the
camera around a lot but once you're in
this spacecraft and you're in space
you're very limited how did you and Tony
figure out about what lens to use what
tilt so we didn't have a whole lot of
choices of where we could put the camera
because the shuttle payload Bay was so
crowded with the hardware that was
necessary to repair the Hubble Space
Telescope so we picked the best the
optimal spot of the delimited things we
had and it turned out that we were right
at the base of the telescope and we had
to tilt up about 18 degrees and we
looked up at at the telescope as it was
sitting in the service structure and the
astronauts would come in and they would
do work inside the telescope and up and
around it and in order to be able to see
the entire telescope we had to use
either a 32mm meter a fisheye or a 40
millimeter regular rectilinear linen so
those were two of our choices and so
that we'd be able to cut between shots
we picked a little longer lens than 62
millimeter to enable us to get punched
in a little bit closer a little bit more
detail and see up inside the bowels and
Space Telescope we worked with a very
interesting group of people asked NASA
called the Doug lab and dung is an
acronym and I forget exactly what it
stands for but they they came up with
the words so that it would spell out the
work done at NASA you get points for
acronyms that they make real words but
anyway we were in this virtual reality
lab and we they modeled our camera in
the cargo bay with the lenses and we
could set in with them and actually go
through every VA and see where the
astronauts are going to be and what we
want to see during different different
spacewalks and this turned out to be a
very useful tool to help us pre
visualize what we're going to see how
wide the Lyne should be
how close we should be when we should
roll the camera and I want to turn it
over now to leo boss a who was really
instrumental in helping design the
cameras and actually the film that went
into that the spacecraft yeah it was the
ICBC had many challenges of which one of
those challenges of getting a roll of
film together that would fit inside the
ICBC camera which is the imax cargo bay
camera and that had to be 5,400 feet
because Kodak didn't have the ability to
make a 5,400 foot roll so we had to
splice the film together and of course
it's negative film and it can't be
exposed to light so making a splice was
a was a challenge we used a film splice
and electro Sonics ultrasonic sorry film
splicer to join the two ends of the roll
together and we had to do this in the
dark had to be such that it was not
didn't change the dimension of the film
in other words the film wasn't thicker
because if the splice was thicker it
would probably jam in the camera so we
had to measure this after we made it and
we had to also trim the flashing on the
at the splice and we had to make sure
that we were handling we were handling
it to make this place that would any
pressure Marx didn't cause a pressure
exposure of the film we made three these
rolls so we had a backup role in case
one got damaged or or or we had to
change out for other reasons the the
roll of film and so that was how we put
together a fifty four hundred foot roll
of film for our camp that's great leo
and so you've got it loaded and we've
got a picture here of the the cargo the
ICBC and putting the the thermal
blankets on it there it is you describe
that to us Leo what they're doing there
sure so to make sure the camera sits at
a relatively comfortable temperature we
had to build a container that would keep
some air pressure inside and that
container being metal had
protected thermally so that any heat
that we generated within the container
to keep the camera warm wouldn't be
conducted out by the container radiated
into space so the thermal blankets
prevent this from happening and it's dry
nitrogen to switch is important too so
that you don't have a oxygen in that
atmosphere and it's dry so that you
don't get any condensation of the
moisture on the let's say the window but
of course is we know that James is going
to tell us about that we actually did
get penny calls from space what what
happened was when they're they're
working out on the on the Hubble
telescope they only had cameras for the
person using the robotic arm to maneuver
the camera that's maneuver the astronaut
and tools and stuff around with and so
they had one decided well we can see it
this particular task better through the
IMAX camera that we can through the NASA
cameras so they had opened it up to look
at this particular spot while they were
in the EBA and then they didn't close it
back down so it sit there looking out at
a dark space and all the heat was
rushing right out of the the front the
glass and it caused condensation you
know like some forms on the inside of
your wind windshield your car deform and
we found out about it we're sitting in
Mission Control and it's late at night
and we get the call that you just don't
want to hear which is houston we have a
problem that we should we have a problem
and it's IMAX so we we figured out what
what caused it and we closed the door up
and ask them about to do that anymore
and fortunately it cleared up the the
fog the heaters inside the camera had to
had the condensation dissipated by the
time we're here we're ready to shoot our
next shot so but it was the typical day
on console during the space flight hours
and hours of sheer boredom followed by
seconds of absolute panic so I went come
back
for a minute tell us a little bit about
you know the 30 perv camera I think we
only well we only made a couple of those
and I think they're in if what one of
our question is for museum so you know
what happened to those cameras the the
thing with this 3d IMAX cameras is that
we couldn't use our previous
developments of 3d IMAX camera systems
they were way too large to put into a
container and or you can put it in in
the orbiter so a new system had to be
developed and basically what they did to
reduce the size of it they made a
movement so that you could expose the
left and right eye image on the same
strip of film side-by-side so that means
as the strip of film goes through the
camera and gets exposed every other
image is a left eye image and every
other image is a right eye image and
when the film is developed then of
course we have to separate the images so
that we can get a left eye sequence and
a right eye sequence for a film
projector and that's how we were able to
get our cameras our new lead about
cameras on board the Michelle you know
in all the space movies we made we
learned about what happens to film in
space not from a physical point of view
but from a from a sense of symmetric
point of view but I wanted James to talk
about what happens to film in space the
speed of the film and what happens to
digital in space there's unique things
you have to overcome over to you James
right right
early on actually the first flights that
we did in I think was 1994 we
experienced some fogging some radiation
damage to the film which causes the
pulse it was like the lights were dim it
up and dim and downed him without
dimming down and and it just pulsed and
we thought it was a lab process during
an era of course it's never the way I
was trying to blame it on me and it's
never it's always David Paul but it
turned out to be high-energy cosmic
particles that above around 280 290
miles you get more of these cosmic
particles and they expose
the high-speed film and caused the
situation and it took us quite a while
to figure that out and finally figured
out that one of the ways to keep it keep
this this high-speed film from fogging
was to stick it in between bags of water
we just stuck the the film in between
those bags and that water slows down
those high-energy cosmic particles
enough to where it doesn't do damage as
quickly it's still damages the film but
not nearly as great and then tell us
what happens with the digital camera in
space with the digital cameras of course
you don't have film you've got a sensor
and that sensor is sensitive to light
that's why it works
so those sensors are made up of millions
of photo sites and if one of the cosmic
particles hits one of those photo sites
just right it can cause it to fail to
short out which means you have a hole in
your picture and if you get enough those
in the holes it makes a bigger hole or
if you get them in enough different
places it makes a lot of spots all over
your picture so we got a few of those on
Hubble because it was at a high altitude
but it wasn't real we weren't there long
enough to really do any super damage to
to those those image sensors and
everything in Hubble that you see that
shot inside the space shuttle is shot
with a small cannon HDTV g1 camcorder
and then uh pressed IMAX and then
converted to 3d so it was quite a test
we asked that little camera to do an
awful lot of work but it was different
ended to do they did a pretty good job
so we talked about the thirty-first
camera we talked about the little Canon
HD camera but we didn't talk much about
the big IMAX 3d camera that you used in
the pool and you also used in what I
like to call the fire boxes so talk
about shooting launches with IMAX
cameras well throughout our history with
IMAX one of the one of the most
demanding and one of the most
interesting shots of course is is a
launch shot everybody loves to be on
that Rumble and in the theater the the
great sound systems that we have you
want to be up close with IMAX so what we
would do we would put camera
in blast-proof explosion-proof boxes up
close to the shuttle sometimes within a
couple hundred feet and sometimes closer
and these cameras were run by remote
control through NASA's launch control
system
so whenever the countdown hits 30
seconds 31 seconds it would send a
signal to start the IMAX camera the IMAX
camera would start up and it would run
and it would she be launched and
everything would go fine but one time
they decided ahead of time to do a test
on the launch control system and they
got to the point where they started our
camera not knowing that whenever they
stopped their test our camera would keep
running so our camera just kept in ran
all the film out without the rocket
going anywhere and so that was one of
the few times that we didn't get the
launch the launch shot that we wanted
because it kind of fit there today
before we didn't go any quicker how
close can you get
the cameras are remote but where are you
sometimes you're abandoning a camera to
actually tell me because the firebox
shots are static the closest they let
anybody get during a launch is one mile
from a shuttle and that was the advanced
rescue crew they were stationed inside a
little m13 tank that they could drive
him up and help astronauts that they had
to in an emergency but everybody else
was at least three miles away so we
would be back at a press side or a
remote camera site and to shoot it with
the IMAX camera that that was man
occasionally we would put a camera on
one of NASA's trackers what they would
do is there would be a guy in launch
control and he would anticipate the
shuttle launching and start to tilt up
so that he could be in time with the
shuttle and he would just follow it up
with this tracker and it's like you have
a man camera right there on the launch
pad but it was run remotely as well so
there's all sorts of tricks we used to
get you up close and personal with these
launches for the movies that we've been
doing
so leo what was like I mean you're in
you're in you know the the headquarters
of NASA you're at consoles you're
listening to astronauts that must have
been a pretty cool thing to be doing yes
it was a very surreal experience since
that's that it's a different world
inside that all this communication going
on and you're having to listen on
various loops
we're also retrieving data we were
monitoring the current buses that were
providing power to our cameras so we had
sort of an indication if a camera had
had done a shot or not because it had a
specific signature that you could see on
the on the on the powered rock and there
were there are other clues that would
help too and and the production people
very much interested in having this
information so they could sort of piece
together these pieces to help them
understand the shot better that was
being made so you know as we move
forward you've got to look to the future
what do you guys you know see is the
future is IMAX IMAX in space you know we
did a beautiful planet
I think our days are probably gone
shooting shooting film and space but
Leah what would you like to see us do
next you know all these space films are
spectacular and when NASA does something
unique it's it's always another
opportunity in which we could film if we
have if if we if we're in the right
position to be able to do that make that
arrangement with them to be able to do
that hopefully I to the moon and let's
put in I would love an IMAX camera on
Mars
someday I hope I live to see that day
what do you think's in our future James
uh well I I would really like to see
some IMAX shot on the moon I think
physically on the moon shooting back at
Earth I got a shot that I want to do you
know how we
the corona of the Sun during solar
eclipse from Earth well we're gonna see
the corona of the Sun blocked out from
the earth blocking it out rather than
the moon blocking of course the Earth's
wouldn't have an atmosphere and so
you're gonna have this these beautiful
sunset colors all the way around the
earth during this Eclipse as well as the
solar corona going out from it I think
it's probably going to be one of the
most stunning sight that a human will
ever see in the very near future apart
from that I think going to Mars is going
to be a great thing to do of course all
these will have to be digital capture
things we can't fly still about the Kurd
back this won't work so looking forward
to getting some really super high res
digital imaging up to now on the moon to
the to the lunar gateway to the Mars
gateway and on to Mars as well I don't
think there's really anything more more
amazing than watching these movies in
the huge big screens IMAX especially
Hubble the 3d sequence IMAX really makes
you understand we're just your little
grains of we're so insignificant things
but makes you really humble and the Dome
systems our Dome systems really are
amazing to really get you immersed you
know Patricia and I in a simply content
last year and we had a feed from the
space station and nobody knew that IMAX
is in the audience what images from the
space program inspired you when you were
younger
so it is like the dream is alive Hill
Columbia I grew up in a small town we
did have an IMAX theater theater
anything so I actually saw my first IMAX
film when I went to Space Camp and it
completely blew my mind and I was
enthralled with it just the fact that
you know with the wraparound screen you
felt completely immersed and every year
that I went back to Space Camp I saw the
same movies but I never got tired of
them there's three or four or five
astronauts as children they saw our
movies and really propelled them into
thinking about being astronauts and
hopefully we continue to do that as we
move forward with new digital capture
techniques new new sound techniques
we've got 12 channels sound now in our
IMAX theatres and I certainly can't wait
along with all my colleagues to get back
to the movies and I thank you both you
guys for being instrumental in getting
getting Hubble made and I think our
theatres and all our partners around the
world who shown it to children and
educated them and we can't wait to
continue so thanks very much guys thank
you thank you to any opportunity great
talking with you bye everybody stay safe
you